all right so we have a tweet here from
Richard medher says this is huge over a
dozen countries have now applied to join
brics including Algeria Iran and
Argentina the multi-polar order is
taking shape before us if expanded
bricks would compromise over half the
global population 60 of global global
gas and 45 of global oil reserves to me
it doesn't sound like multipolar just
sounds like the end of The Americans
sounds like bipolar is what it sounds
like no no it's the end of the United
States it is the Pedro dollar yeah yeah
it'll be it'll be the death of the Petro
dollar no doubt I mean I hate to say
this but this is what I was talking
about on the last show like about bricks
no that the the end of America being a
superpower like people aren't really
ready for that but it's not it's they
don't know what it's like to not be in a
country that can just flip a switch and
say I want things Tim do you know are
they doing are they doing an actual
currency with this or is it is it just I
mean are they going to launch a currency
that's going to back this up
I bet it'll be a crypto of some sort
because
when they were doing uh when the EU was
first launching they were selling it was
I think it was five cents on the dollar
you could buy the Euros before they
launched the before they fully launched
I I if this is if they're gonna make a
currency out of this I want it
yeah there's a news article from October
7 2022 their Putin said he plans on
creating a quote new Global Reserve
currency yeah it's going to be a central
bank digital currency and I would be
willing to bet you know I'm not saying
it's true I'm saying it's hyper
speculative highly speculative but I
would not be surprised if American
Elites are purposefully tanking the us
while sending their assets over through
maybe like Panama where a lot of money
was stored or Switzerland and and we
know uh Joe Biden flew on Air Force two
with his son Hunter to for a private
Equity deal in China I think the elites
they are they are stealing the
silverware from the Titanic after the
iceberg was hit 2008 they're jumping on
the Lifest telling everyone buddy
everything's fine don't worry about it
taking those lifeboats off to another
big ship loading up all this over coming
back and saying everything's okay people
don't worry about it they're getting
ready to jump ship
I would buy that I think that explains a
lot of the Ukraine uh the Ukraine
business and I explain I think that
explains a lot a lot
so it's just that economics doesn't care
about American Republicans no way it
never has America economics I've never
cared avoid saying the thing we're not
supposed to say but it also has to do
with
so
um the fact that 2008 happened and
nothing ever came of it and they needed
something to blame it on and distract
for a while and also to control
populations they had to do that and then
do what Tim's talking about see see what
I did there it didn't
so it's like figure it out folks maybe
you're talking about the global the I
just call it the bank for international
settlements in Switzerland printing
selling the Federal Reserve money
talking about something else well I I I
think I know a fever and and the bank of
international settlements is the old
system what they're proposing now with
bricks is going to be to get off of that
system
so when when Russia invades Ukraine they
threaten to rip them rip them from Swift
and so immediately they're like okay we
need something else because we cannot be
beholden to the U.S I'd be willing to
bet so they immediately started going
around and this this is years ago in
fact we know they were doing this and
pitching to these countries join us the
resistance and now with Ukraine and
everything that's going on and the US is
in total chaos I'd be willing to bet
and again this is very surface level
because I don't have access to class
that information I'd be willing to bet
that China's been subverting the us
through Tick Tock and through social
media our foreign adversaries have been
doing the same thing we have been
spinning around rope-a-dope while
they've been preparing all of this stuff
and there are Elites in the United
States who know what's happening and
said you know what if you can't beat
them join them no that's not only what's
happened but look at you can actually
look at this if you look at the bill
that just came out about unveiling who
runs the think tanks it's not just that
they've been rope-a-doping they have
been cashing out on this like they're
every single think tank in Washington DC
is owned by a different foreign country
and they're not like our friends they're
not like
England I mean even though England is
our actual biggest enemy people need to
start understanding
um it's like really really bad ones like
ones that are on like the state
department in one hand is creating lists
of bad countries that are sanctioned and
on the other hand sending their staff
over to work at think tanks that are
funded by those countries so like make
that make sense for me like that's
that's that it's not just it's not as
innocent even as rope-a-dope like I
think what Tim saying actually is
completely correct I just think it's a
gazillion times worse than that what do
we do just get some chickens get a gun
yeah you're on the right path watch
power watch the fall of the US Empire
well we're participating in it we also
forgot how they're shipping in all the
drugs to pacify the general the borders
and destroying men and testosterone so
no one could Rebel and fight listen when
this is when all of this is happening
and then our border is completely porous
they don't care drugs are pouring and
they don't care our economy is
completely destroyed they don't care
I'm just like okay they're participating
in it yeah yeah
I have to take some responsibility for
this yeah it's not it's not just bite
like in a trump Administration do you
know what happened to the immigration
bill it was shelved by the same people
that are running afpi right now which is
why I'm in a big old fight with them and
why like they're all can't understand
why I'm coming after them on Twitter but
like the same exact people that are
running afpi are the ones that decided
to shelve the immigration bill in favor
of having Kim Kardashian's uh uh more
more moments with celebrities like that
and release more criminals because all
that was at the top of the list of all
the Americans America First was
definitely about let's release more
criminals early not do immigration do
tax policy and plant a thousand trees I
don't remember that in any rally but
that's what we did and I hate I'm saying
we because I was in that office so it's
like I that wasn't what I was working on
like we were working on the immigration
bill and I can tell you it would have
solved all a lot of these issues do you
know that there's so much
um the the amount the number of
um uh what are they called those things
you put on trucks that come in through
ships like the shipping containers
they're that big right not just the
little FedEx package a package a giant
box that big the number of those that
are uninspected coming through our ports
is so low is so low that the number
itself is classified I'm not saying
anything classified by saying that if
the number is classified because if the
American people knew it would freak them
out that badly I don't think they care I
think we knew we found out that Joe
Biden was shipping children illegal
immigrant children across the country
and it was a story only for people who
read the news and half the country
despite the you know here's what I see
I see this story in front of us the
Petro dollar has been at risk for a long
time since the 70s since the 70s but
it's been getting progressively worse in
the past several years five six seven
years ago Russia starts dumping U.S
bonds China they've been preparing for
this the people running this country
they literally don't care Donald Trump
starts showing up our borders showing up
our defenses sealing our border bringing
jobs back getting factories from Mexico
back in boy did they lose their minds
and we've talked about this it may be
because of thucydides trap which is this
historical uh concept that whenever a a
large the dominant economic power is
about to be displaced by a rising
economic economic power War breaks out
at least 12 out of the 16 times in the
past 500 years so perhaps what's
happening is they're saying to avoid
world war three we will control
demolition the United States and then
rebuild up where it's growing rapidly
say China the brics countries and thus
we are watching the complete and total
collapse of of our country and what
happens is with expanded Universal
mail-in voting the American people who
are so blinded so stupid so ignorant and
so hate-filled are voting themselves
into Oblivion and you know what this is
what I was saying earlier I'm much I'm
very very much about individualism so my
my worst case scenario is it's not my
preferred ideal that this country goes
belly up but
you know I'm I'm fine with trying to
figure things out for myself and not
having to rely on other people and I and
I'm not saying I will be good at
surviving completely in the wilderness
no but you know I I we that this is one
of the reasons we get out to the middle
of nowhere we install solar panels with
massive batteries we get backup
generators we buy copper wires do that
though they if the country completely
falls apart there's not going to be a
they anymore it's going to be roving
bands of people desperate for food and
then what happens is communities isolate
each other call it a national divorce
whatever you want where we are right now
this is Maga country the the all the
neighbors out here they got big signs
flying the Trump Flags in in a second if
there was a major crisis there would be
a a a neighborhood watch meeting people
would know exactly what to do and how to
do it people would be fortified I'm not
saying I'm doing anything crazy prep or
like like Preppers do maybe we should
because because this is very alarming
the brics countries but I mean like 30
years worth of food and like you know
look it is enough I mean not if it's the
total I mean well yeah I mean but if
you're still if three years have gone by
you're still living on some bagged up
some badge you know fast food no no no
no listen listen here's what you do when
you store emergency food for the
apocalypse scenario yeah you never touch
it what you do is you always make sure
you're getting your food from natural
sources and only in extreme emergencies
do you do you tap into your your your
reserves after three years ain't gonna
be no Chef Boyardee anymore no that's
going to be worth gold there's gonna be
some dude and he's going to be like
you're an unopened Chef Boyardee that's
right no no I want that case of nine
millimeter I'll give you anything for it
he opens it and there's mud in it
no no the cans just faded and filthy oh
I think would you get for a pack of
Hubba Bubba
you know he cracks it open takes his
finger and just puts it in his mouth and
then instantly in his mind is
transported to being a little kid in a
beautiful suburb and his mom hands him
the bowl and he's like I love you mom
she's like I love you and then he
flashes back to reality his clothes are
ripped he's covered in dirt and he's
like
I don't know why that's funny I love
this movie I was talking to him I was
talking to Michael malice earlier he's
got a book coming out but he one thing
he said one of the things he said to me
was people in this country absolutely do
not realize what bad is that's what I'm
trying to say because he's the an expert
on North Korea what I'm trying to say is
like and and many other countries like
that what I'm trying to say is we don't
know we are so not prepared for what
it's like to not be a superpower I think
what what I'm saying is like getting to
the point where you're at where it's
like okay fine maybe there isn't a bay
maybe it is roving gangs and maybe at
all that and everybody else everyone is
an influencer you know everyone in
Poland in my family jars their food has
a little plot of land where they grow
there yeah the Mormons will be we do
that because the Communists starved my
family so people don't understand how
bad it could get you could get really
bad really quick and it's only about us
that's right I'm becoming I'm going to
become Amish we're gonna go to super
chats okay yeah last thing is I one
thing that could happen because we're
not an Empire I mean it might look kind
of empirical you know there's a bridge
we are an American Republic and when the
Roman Republic fell it became an Empire
so if some strong man steps in and says
run turns this country into a junta and
runs it through the military goes around
kills whoever disagrees yeah if
something like a caesar were to appear
with a military force and people and
then we're like second fiddle to the
Chinese superstructure and we're just
kind of like a vassal State no first we
get to be the American Empire though
for 200 years no we need we need the
American Caesar and that's why when we
get the red Caesar we're gonna have a
handful of hundred years of good times
and that's going to be awesome and then
everything can fall apart but first I
insist on a red Caesar thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time